RuPaul's Drag con la 2219 we are just
moments away from the ribbon-cutting
ceremony for the Saturday festivities
and look I mean RuPaul's here all the
season eleven queens are here so many
drag celebrities are here and the crowd
is simply excited they cannot wait this
is an event like no other the only kind
of it of its kind in the world and like
I said a minutes away from RuPaul
kicking off today's and here he is
[Music]
trying to get the scoop thank you thank
you how do I look
[Music]
what we are here to entertain to
celebrate and to spread the love
welcome to drag all right we're starting
Saturday of RuPaul's Drag con la 2019 we
have Bryce sander who is hanging out in
the et live stage it's gonna be a great
day tons of interviews with your
favorite drag celebrities interviews
with RuPaul Michelle visage Carson
Kressley Ross Matthews and just a lot of
lgbtq+ celebrities fun times you guys
you can you can catch all the fun at our
a patty T live download the app or go to
ET live.com again we're going to give
you the full drag con experience all
weekend long we're gonna throw it to
Bryce who is hanging out at the et live
stage we are so close to the main stage
we're gonna be in the middle of all the
action talking to all your favorite
Queens right here all weekend long taken
in everything around us this is gonna be
a wild weekend a one-of-a-kind weekend
we're so excited you're joining us here
for ET live drag Con is officially open
on this Saturday all the Queen's are
here and if you couldn't make it out to
LA at least you're here on each alive to
watch us I think we're taking a look at
the crowd right now there's Yuriko hair
I it's either Eureka or Nina I can't
tell it's in the back of the head but
it's a beautiful Queen nonetheless look
at all these fans so excited to be here
RuPaul mixing and mingling saying hi to
the kids I love this is a family
friendly affair over here it's like I
said a one-of-a-kind we cannot it's Nina
West I got eyes on her Nina West not
Yuriko Hara looking glam beautiful I
mean people already are living their
best lives it is only 9 a.m. here on the
west coast
alright so stick with the stream all
weekend long we will bring be bringing
you all the best from Jack on LA 2019
you don't want to miss it stick with us